previously on TV sins favorite dirty
women they were [ __ ] and God made Eve
from the river bed Oh get it it's like
when Rick woke up in the original series
but now it's upside down and totally
different are you not entertained also
show begins with the opening of eyes
cliche oh yeah Lauria oh Jesus I haven't
heard someone call for Gloria this much
since Laura Branigan in 1982 button
flies why does it always have to be
flickering overhead lights in horror
content this place may be rundown but
there is electricity that the zombies
chew halfway through the power supply or
something considering he's been running
down the middle of this street rude
completely unobstructed for a while now
a driver somehow not seeing him and
hitting him at the speed seems either
impossible or intentional or driven also
what was he doing driving that fast
towards an obvious dead end wrinkles
also it was modern day the whole time
this opening reveal somehow makes the
twist in the village look subtle on
behalf of tall people everywhere stop
hanging things from door frames or we
will stop getting things off higher
shelves for you this is a team effort
people should have got your ass out of
bed thirty minutes ago everyone's
running late for no reason because it's
just a requirement at this point for
maximum intensity you're raving about
flesh blood and viscera viscera you guys
should have seen the viscera I've never
seen so much viscera in my life yes this
sounds exactly like what it might have
said I don't know what this was told you
so what are we saying the witnesses use
that word or the cops did nope a
scriptwriter used that word humans say
guts we say guts I tell ya it's dad
listen I don't want to go after almost
10 minutes this is starting to feel more
like fear the family drama a lot of kids
are sick today thought you were another
victim so are we supposed to think these
sick kids have something to do with the
coming outbreak or is it just a weak
connective reference the writers think
is a sly wink well the show ever
actually care to explain any of the
details because five sins to cover you
while you're pondering that answer hand
it over
what's going on Tobias has this
contraband to fight off the zombie horde
but um seriously he's gonna take those
mothers on with the equivalent of a
homemade prison ship the
know if it's a virus or microbe not sure
why the show feels the need to play the
pronoun game we know there are zombies
we came for some bees if there's a
problem we're gonna know about it
yeah why haven't they yet Nick saw
gloria eating that dude in the middle of
day yesterday and there were several
other bodies there that would turn into
zombies themselves short ly after death
and they were in a well populated area
so again I asked why haven't they yet
seen your project it's supposed to be
fun what'll be fun is coming back and
tagging later does this school recruit
the country's best Perfetti artists most
schools are lucky to have two kids that
can draw something that doesn't involve
stick figures and that cool pointy s
thing some of the world's greatest
artists couldn't pull this it off a
nightmare it's clearly day out well
writer and while I'm not saying you
should go with Daymare I am saying maybe
this is a good opportunity to use the
phrase bad dream when I went easily
verifiable facts that are easily
verified by authorities still haven't
been verified easily and if it didn't
come from the powder then it came out of
me did you make lightning or feel the
pain of a dying deer cuz then it
definitely came from the powder
yeah isn't Travis a [ __ ] high school
teacher
why is he throwing all Barney Fife here
on the church instead of oh I don't know
learning the cops even if there weren't
a flesh-eating monster in here there's
still a big-ass drug ring being
conducted can we talk about the fact
that this toilet is directly underneath
a giant window on the ground level who
would unloose the caboose while their
back is that vulnerable to the outside
world what the hell is the light coming
in through this window when the sky was
completely darkness and he needed a
flashlight when he arrived a few seconds
ago I guess since the Sun rises in the
West maybe mourning happens fast in
California wait well you repeat the same
behavior and expect different results
it's merriam-webster crazy actually
according to merriam-webster it's marked
by a thought or action that lacks reason
maybe Berkeley needs to have better
entrance exams I win no I appreciate it
the shooting gallery I found it last
night East Room
it's the pronoun game not the verb game
is you cannot enable okay a little miss
cover for the kid who brought the night
to school and let him off with a warning
I don't think he's lying oh so you think
someone ate someone based on the first
30 minutes of this show I do not
seriously has any car alarm actually
made this noise since 1998 only few
hours away same state same timezone same
bat-channel from the moment he starts
drawing this heart to the complete
version is less than two minutes now
that might be fine but I went back and
painstakingly watched the scene for you
and he's literally casually drawing on
her arm for a maximum 18 seconds during
that time meaning he drew this entire
thing in less than 20 seconds I mean I
know it's not Picasso but I'm calling
bull on all this beautiful field work
aside from the one zombie at the
beginning this show has been so
goddamned all that I feel like I'm
watching the most depressing episode of
Riverdale also doesn't Madison have any
actual work to do she's honestly just
kind of lurking around the hallways and
peeping in on classes and she's supposed
to be guiding sing there's a man tried
to cut the damn dog open to keep his
hands warm nice gruesome wait that
concept wasn't new to the Empire Strikes
Back dang it now I have to hate that
movie because it didn't use 100%
original ideas well man versus nature
London's trying to teach us how not to
die
nature shadowing party thought he might
be a zombie but he wasn't a zombie so
aren't we clever this is going to
continue to happen a lot isn't it see
here's the thing hospitals would have
had this figured out in no time it's the
dirty little secret of the zombie verse
if the Living Dead thing ever goes down
the way it's usually portrayed we'd
figure it out quickly and then just have
new death procedures within a few months
time there would be some initial panic
but we'd get back to normal in no time
which doesn't bode well for a show set
during all that origin nonsense but once
he removes all the doodads alarms would
be going off left and right because the
machines would register a loss of
heartbeat and pulse but that doesn't
happen here because TV show the sequence
makes Nick out to be Harrison forward
and the [ __ ] fugitive but this isn't
hard man he's not under arrest and he's
an adult the restraints were there for
his own safety so bailing on the
hospital ain't the Great Escape or
anything
Wittering bye son
Madison has the same empathic abilities
as Forest Whitaker and species
[Music]
the music's telling me I need to be
scared of something but my best guess is
smog sure the obvious thing to do when
coming upon the bedding of an
intravenous heroin addict is to blindly
stick your hand into the covers don't
worry she's been trained for this folks
after all she is a high school guidance
counselor no one will be seated during
the scenes of intense texting action
we're gonna find him he doesn't want to
be found
skip I'm just tired of waiting on the
call from the morgue right there a few
calls before the morgue
look I'm not trying to be insensitive
here but that call about your overdosed
son who was now decaying in a back alley
somewhere is probably coming from the
police okay maybe I'm trying to be a bit
insensitive you see anything no me
neither and I've been watching this
whole episode I'd love to see anything
other than these morose mothers arguing
about family life mmm five and you miss
a few stops good to see the principal is
out for his daily count of each child as
they come off the bus duty how very
expositional of him Lucas how they
unload on him how he keeps coming and I
gotta call the district see how they
want to play this
what is it necessary for the school
district of Los Angeles County to
formally weigh-in on a completely
unrelated news story call your parents
were there I know right what are the
odds I want you home okay I'm so
concerned about what's going on I'm
sending you home by yourself LA River is
the setting for part of a movie or TV
show that is set in la clé [ __ ] come on
jeez can overreact much if this is how
you handle it every time one of your
clients ends up in the hospital he must
be super great at digging human size
holes in the ground by now what a
strange place to park I mean I know this
isn't exactly a trip to the mall but
stopping there means nothing else can go
through and you still have to come
further out to turn around and go back
it's literally the worst possible place
to stop and park your car unless you're
going to back out of there and set up
some sort of force [ __ ] there it is
me man even when this show finally
decides to zombie it's boring as hell I
have no idea but at least this show
eventually make sure and explore all the
details of what happened since we came
all this way back to the beginning of it
all instead of immediately just becoming
another escape the zombies Gore fest
right right
we tell it to get you Barbara you're
raving about flesh blood and viscera I'm
not sure that I agree with you a hundred
percent on your police work they're
local
hey there girlie how you don't sweating
like a pig actually in yourself yes I
did it I killed a vet I hated her so
much it
the Fiat flame flames flames
instead of being cyber bullies maybe we
can all be cyber buddies think about
this what is the most exciting thing
that can happen on TV or in movies or in
real life somebody's a gun